welcome to exploring computing
today's video is computer hardware
part two a closer look at processing
in this video i'd like to take a closer
look at the processing
component of our computers as we saw in
the last video
processing is one of the most important
components of a computer
and as you may know the most important
processing component is the central
processing unit or the cpu
but there's actually a bit more going on
here and so i wanted to
highlight a few things first of all just
so
everyone's clear on what we're talking
about if you've got a computer
here are some of the common names for
processors you might run into
if you've got an intel processor the
most common intel processors on consumer
level computers are
core i3 core i5 core i7 and core i9
if you've got a computer with an amd
processor
the common consumer level cpus for them
are ryzen and athlon
now one of the things about the cpu is
the cpu tends to be a big bottleneck
as we've seen all processing
goes through the cpu so in order to
actually do anything
the cpu has to do all the work
memory can remember things but
ultimately in order for our computer to
actually
act as a computer device the cpu needs
to execute
now there's a couple ways around this
one of them is
we've started to get multi-core
cpus honestly in some respects this is
less because we really need multiple
cores and more because
the electrical engineers have not been
good at getting
cpu speeds faster for a long time every
year
cpus got faster and faster and faster
and now we're starting to plateau out on
the speed so
the electrical engineers are like hey we
can't make the processor any faster but
would you like more processors we can
give you two cores we can give you four
cores we can give you six
cores we give you eight cores and here's
the thing about multi-core processors
you know having a few cores is useful
but in terms of actually being able to
take advantage of
four or six or eight cores a lot of it
depends upon the type of work you're
doing
so if you kind of think about it like if
i'm word processing how am i going to
take advantage of the multi-course
and it turns out that this is actually
an issue for programmers because
programmers often don't know how to take
advantage of the multiple cores in a
multi-core processor so
ideally if you want your application to
run quickly
and you know you're running on a
computer that has multiple cores
you want your application to take
advantage of as many cores as possible
and
this has been kind of a problem i think
programmers are getting a bit better at
it but
you know what i remember when the first
video game consoles came out with
multiple chords this was a huge deal
with the
gaming programmers like okay i've got
you know eight cores how am i going to
take advantage of these eight course i
don't know what to do how to split up
the work that my program needs to do in
order to do these eight cores
so if i've got microsoft word what am i
going to do with more than one chord
it's not always clear there are however
some applications that can definitely
take advantage of multi-core processors
so some things that
multi-core processors could be really
good at
if you're doing photo processing
you can basically split up the photo
into different parts
and so you can have one core handle one
part another core handle another part
and a third core handle the third part
i've got a little bit of a demo here so
suppose we have a photograph of
this is my old dog molly the flow pep so
named because
um when i was a resident fellow in flomo
for 12 years
um for any grad students listening that
aren't stanford grads
uh that's the equivalent of illegal
housemaster
um molly was my dog when i was
in west flow so i suppose we want to
convert this image of her
in color and we want to convert to black
and white
so what i've got here is i've got a
little demonstration of what this might
look like with
a single core and then multiple cords
i've deliberately increased the size of
the pixels for this demo
so it's much clearer exactly what's
going on
okay so our simulation is going to start
off showing what would happen with one
processor and you can see that this is
working
we're just going along and processing
each of the pixels one at a time
now if we switch to two processors
you can see it's really easy to just
split it up and say hey the top half of
the picture
one processor bottom half second
processor you go up to four
again way faster and then finally we're
going to do eight
and you can see that this really easy to
just break this process down to take
advantage of
additional cores because there's a clear
way to divide up the work
and so if we're doing tasks like say
weather simulations again really easy to
figure out how to use multiple cores
just to assign different courses to
different parts of the country
and in fact super computers have many
many cores like
literally tens of thousands of cores and
they're often used for simulation work
for this very reason
in addition to multi-core processors
though there's another way we can kind
of get around
the cpu bottleneck and that is adding in
specialized processors and so
modern computers generally have in
addition to their main central
processing unit which may be multi-core
they also have a graphics processing
unit
graphics processing units are probably
best known by consumers for their
ability to
create 3d graphics for games
here we've got a screenshot from
assassin's creed odyssey
but the gpu can be used for other
purposes as well
they can be used for photo or video
editing
they can also be used for artificial
intelligence and neural networks
um they've rather infamously been used
for bitcoin mining
in fact the bitcoin miners use of
graphical processing units has really
raised the prices and gamers are
somewhat upset about this
plus it turns out the bitcoin miners are
using a lot of
electricity and it's really bad for the
environment
anyway i just wanted to give you an idea
of what the different
things that are going on with processes
are